[Musica]
attenzione scuola la scuola è in
pericolo
la scuola è un pericolo
già perché la scuola ha innescato tre
ordigni pericolosissimi il primo è
l'ordigno del controllo e crea un sacco
di ansia negli insegnanti nei ragazzi
nei dirigenti scolastici dei genitori e
in tutte le persone che ci vivono
intorno il secondo ordigno
la formalizzazione che diventa
burocrazia estrema che irrigidisce tutto
è il terzo ordigno è la valutazione che
purtroppo signori è una valutazione
meramente performativa e che di nuovo
crea ansia paura angoscia
insomma la scuola auto innescato questi
ordigni e sta implodendo
attenzione allora io sono qua per
raccontarvi di un grande sogno che sto
portando avanti con le scuole che si
sono accorte di questi ordigni che
vogliono provare a disinnescarle per
trasformarla nel palazzo delle
meraviglie
già perché se noi disinneschi amo queste
tre ordigni
abbiamo tre meraviglie il atri la prima
dal controllo alla libertà e sapete bene
che la libertà è la caratteristica
fondamentale del nostro farci sempre più
umani
il secondo dalla burocrazia dalla
formalizzazione alla creatività e sapete
anche questo molto bene soprattutto qui
al ted quanto la creatività sia molto
meno caotica di quanto si pensi che
necessiti molto più re
di quanto non si pensi
il terzo dalla valutazione alla
valorizzazione dell'essere umano che ha
bisogno certo anche di momenti
performativi ma che permette alla
persona di valorizzare il proprio
potenziale di manifestarsi per quello
che è nelle sue diverse dimensioni bene
con queste immagini che state iniziando
a vedere che sono di luigi ghirri un
fotografo emiliano degli anni 70 che ha
affascinato ispirato mondi diversi
il mondo dell'architettura lavorando con
alto rossi il mondo degli artisti perché
innamorato degli ambienti degli spazi
per chi usa un linguaggio così poetico
il linguaggio degli intimisti io vorrei
accompagnarmi in un percorso anche molto
intimo che ho sviluppato insieme a
designer e architetti per accompagnare
le scuole a ripensarsi a costruire un
nuovo progetto di scuola
abbiamo scoperto che lo spazio aiuta
tanto a disinnescare questi ordigni
perché lo spazio racconta e vederne
oppure qui che cosa ci racconta questo
spazio che appunto ha trovato una sua
forma per raccontare una certa cosa
dieci passi per trasformare la scuola è
il frutto di un lavoro di alcuni anni
che stiamo svolgendo tra pedagogia
architettura e design
il primo passo è quello di capire che
progettare una scuola il progetto di una
scuola è il frutto di un equilibrio fra
competenze linguaggi diversi e per
capire questo ho dovuto conoscere degli
architetti che parlano la lingua
completamente diversa dalla mia
due architetti di bressanone dove da
dove vengo anche io che costruivano
scuole fende atm matteo scaioli con i
quali ci siamo conosciuti abbiamo
iniziato a fare un percorso insieme
io che insegnava all'università i futuri
insegnanti come fare scuola e loro che
facevano le scuole abbiamo scoperto
insieme come capirsi e molto complicate
come la scuola sia il frutto di una rete
di relazioni molto complessa costruire
un linguaggio insieme a un grosso nostro
obiettivo il secondo passo è quello di
capire che la scuola così com'è e come
la conosciamo forse non basta più
palazzo delle meraviglie avevo detto
prima
ed è proprio così le scuole oggi sono
delle trincee sono pericolose siamo in
trincea sono dei luoghi poco accoglienti
poco ospitali sono ci sono barriere
dappertutto barriere di banchi barriere
di tavoli barriere di muri un dirigente
scolastico che mi ha accompagnato a
scoprire la scuola come luogo dove stare
bene e josé facile dirigente scolastico
di monguelfo quasi al confine con i
territori e nord europei che ha fatto
della sua scuola un laboratorio e che mi
hanno raccontato fin dall'inizio del mio
cammino nel ripensamento delle scuole
quanto la scuola potesse diventare come
una casa un luogo dove stare bene quanto
più possibile un luogo dove non hai
voglia di andar via
il terzo passo per ripensare la scuola è
quello di desiderare in fondo nei
processi partecipati arriviamo qua e
finiamo il percorso desiderare e come
questa rosa è un profumo meraviglioso no
il desiderio ha un bellissimo profumo ha
già qualche si presentano già alcuni
elementi di quello che non va nella
scuola e di quello che si vorrebbe che
diventasse ma si dice che il desiderio
non ha gambe per correre o non
riesce a diventare ancora un progetto
e sapete perché perché il desiderio e
caotico e confuso ma non solo
non posso desiderare niente di quello
che io non conosco e per questo è
importante fare un altro passo cioè
quello di vedere vedere cose nuove
vedere cose diverse e quando andiamo
nelle scuole con accompagniamo questi
gruppi
questi dirigenti scolastici visionarie
questi a volte sindaci a volte
insegnanti che sognano di disinnescare
questi terribili ordigni che stanno
implodendo nella scuola li portiamo a
vedere scuole diverse ma soprattutto li
invitiamo in confrontarsi tra loro come
parlano dirigente è diverso da come
parla un insegnante come parla un
architetto è diverso da come parla un
amministratore locale
ognuno segue una traiettoria ma insieme
vedendo le scuole possono imparare a
conoscersi e capirsi e possono aprire
l'orizzonte scoprire che esiste anche
qualcos'altro
rispetto a quello che hanno desiderato e
da qui arriviamo al prossimo passo che è
un po il cuore il mio grande come dire
bambino nel percorso di accompagnamento
delle scuole che è quello di invitare le
persone i gruppi di lavoro a sognare a
mollare gli ormeggi della razionalità ed
iniziare a legarsi più e dei bisogni
profondi quindi di collegare il progetto
a un'emozione chiediamo spesso alle
comunità di chiudere gli occhi e questo
potreste farlo anche voi ed immaginare
se entrasse nella scuola pur non essendo
anche voi persone di scuola di
immaginare un luogo dove state proprio
bene e le persone quando scott cercano
questo luogo nella scuola riescono a
costruire un'immagine di scuola che ha
un vero senso per loro e da lì
nascono dei bellissimi progetti perché
si comincia a raccontare il proprio
sogno
e perché non è solo un racconto ma
perché poi dopo noi mettiamo le persone
in gruppi in tavoli di lavoro con del
materiale a modellizzare il sogno allora
se io faccio un sogno
tu fai un sogno tu fai un sogno e
insieme dobbiamo rendere restituirlo con
un modello il mio sogno il tuo sogno è
il sogno di un'altra persona diventa un
sogno condiviso che rispetta le qualità
di ciascuno sogno e che però diventa
qualcosa di più modellizzare ci permette
di fare lavorare le mani che dicono così
dice un professore di bonn che
accompagna molte scuole nel processo di
ripensamento
le mani sono molte più sagge della testa
seguono un percorso come il corpo il
corpo è più saggio della testa e così
facendo questo percorso permettiamo alle
persone di presentare dei progetti
progetti non finiti i progetti in fieri
e di manifestare la bellezza del loro
sogno per manifestare la bellezza del
mio sogno di avere qualcosa di concreto
in mano e devo saperlo raccontare come
stiamo raccontando up the sono i speaker
i nostri grandi sogni e vi assicuro
quando io sono comunque mi gruppi nelle
scuole che raccontano i loro modelli io
mi commuovo perché sono bellissimi e
parlano una lingua stupenda che la
lingua della nuova scuola ma dopo aver
sognato e modellizzato e li lavoriamo
molto sulle emotivamente giochiamo anche
perché dobbiamo riportare il gioco e
nella società la qualità del gioco che
sapete bene i creativi stanno bene che
giocare e anche creare ed è molto più
serio di quanto non si creda
abbiamo bisogno di ritornare a una
dimensione più astratta abbiamo bisogno
di
formalizzare abbiamo bisogno di rendere
il progetto qualche cosa da portare su
diversi tavoli tavoli anche di quelli
che non hanno sognato insieme a noi e
quindi abbiamo bisogno di creare degli
schemi quando accompagniamo le scuole
nel loro progetto appunto è importante
che io pedagogista mi accompagno con un
progettista un architetto perché
l'architetto sa molto bene come fare uno
schema funzionale della scuola e come
far tradurre il sogno di questa scuola
in numeri in forme in schemi che possono
essere anche leggibili da
un'amministrazione locale bene quella
che io sento come una grande missione
nella scuola ma anche nel mio ruolo di
professoressa universitaria con i miei
studenti quelle di insegnare a
inquadrare una visione insegnare a
individuare questi ordigni ea scoprire
le meraviglie che potrebbe avere il
palazzo delle conoscenze dove fare
cultura insieme che forse un giorno non
si chiamerà più scuola perché oggi con
scuola davvero leghiamo dei degli script
che non sono più adatti a questo tempo è
quello che più mi preme ed è quello di
insegnare o comunque di dire agli
insegnanti e dirigenti e gli studenti di
sperimentare
io ho inquadrato una visione ho un'idea
di scuola oa un'idea di me voglio
iniziare a correre
voglio ballare il tango o un inquadrato
un'idea ma per riuscire a padroneggiarla
per riuscire a ballare il tango davvero
in una maniera perfetta ed elegante ho
bisogno di tempo
ho bisogno di provare bisogno di
sperimentare ho bisogno di ballare
cinque minuti forse al giorno e poi sono
stanca non ce la faccio più non si
cambia da un giorno all'altro le
rivoluzioni sono fatte di piccole passe
goccia a goccia
quindi io accompagno le scuole
soprattutto in questo dopo che hanno
trovato l'idea dopo
che l'hanno formalizzata l'architettura
prende il suo il suo percorso e anche lì
ci vuole tanto tempo per attivare tutta
la macchina che porta la costruzione di
una scuola
e intanto la scuola sperimenta e così
inizia un grande percorso un percorso in
continua costruzione che non finisce mai
io in questo sono pronta
e voi
[Applauso]